what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude yo
you did you did well huh i'm gonna do so
much better watch this yeah i will
i'm gonna do so much better than you
dude
see you later man i'm gonna do so much
better than you
i didn't realize there's a there's a
starbucks in my guest room
there's a starbucks how did you not know
wait a minute how do you not know go in
i don't know wait a minute so they
started like someone paid the franchise
fee and had
you know what i guess so this was
yesterday there's some employees there's
three employees
three people around here yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy other customers
yeah they've been people coming it's
actually one of those uh starbucks what
i don't know what they call them but i
was trying to ask the employee but i was
so tired let's go to bed
um and uh because it's a 24 i guess it's
24. do they work for you
that's a [ __ ] major starbucks
statement i know i should be making some
sort of
money right yeah do they you know what
they might close but i don't know
does your starbucks have the new like uh
the new
chicken tortilla egg sous vide oh that
yeah not just the other two
yeah the bacon and gruyere yeah and then
there's yes
well they say they have that but they're
always out oh [ __ ] they're always out of
their
popular right dude he really has a
starbucks in it it's cool too because if
i don't have a um
if i don't have a phone charger they
have those [ __ ] table chargers yeah
i can just go on and just place my phone
on there so you had to know that when
you went in there you're like put a
starbucks here and then this
now do you allow anybody into the
starbucks or is there a
they they yeah i mean yeah you can let
anybody in
mostly i would say it's it's mostly
white people and then okay
wow man i i have nothing to do with it
why is it just
why is it no i have nothing to say not
just white people just mostly white
and who else that's a bonus
i said mostly is that
i'm trying i'm not trying to i'm not
trying to is it are you saying that you
have a
i'm not a white only starbucks
i don't care i'm not judging you no i i
know and and again it has
nothing to do with me this is your home
it's in your home christmas in your
house you've been saying that for the
past five minutes
i didn't i didn't i didn't have a i
didn't know
yeah now we gotta we gotta talk about
you're talking about a guy who's gotta i
mean i've got a big house right
every time he talks about the size of
his house he stays in his mouth
but you have no no a racist no i
don't have anything okay but you do
admit that they did there is a starbucks
in my home that's a coffee shop
i found out about that yesterday about
what that that it's is it is that white
people only are there by coincidence or
is there a
barrier to entry to people who have more
melanin in their skin
so i popped in about five or six times
yesterday because i
i still every time i was like wait a
minute really and i would walk in and
i'd be like this is your home
yeah okay my home yeah and every time i
walk in maybe six seven eight nine times
it's a lot yeah there were it was pretty
much
white people okay and they don't only
that okay
is there a sign or anything so it's
starbucks so they do have signs yeah
they have a bunch of signs but they have
that sign that says starbucks and then
they have a sign that says um
things on this premises may cause cancer
and birth defects or whatever that
[ __ ] sign is yeah they have to have
that one yeah
and then uh oh we can res right we have
the right to refuse service to anyone
and then a bunch of
yeah you know that's not and then what
else is there anything is there anything
there was there was
small wording under that which one do
you remember what that said
uh under that we re we reserved a right
to refuse service to anyone
and then a bunch of stuff under that
that was in parentheses did it say of
color
no i it said something like
because when i got closer to the side
because it was small right yeah yeah
yeah but they were like
it said no black
oh boy chris chris that's a super
you have a you have whites on legions
i have nothing to do do you have an
experience you have to do
this in your house you're going to be
responsible for it no matter what and
have it i don't give a [ __ ] who you
bring this to
any court in the land and i mean the
land will say
you had it in your house sir right right
here right and all the evidence
there's a room in your house excuse me
judge i didn't know that no no hold on
but you do now and here's the thing you
guys can judge guys
chris you've known for a day that you
have a white only room in your house
it's not a room it's a starbucks it is a
starbucks
i think obviously starbucks would be in
a lot of trouble let's call it a
starbucks it doesn't matter if it's a
room or a starbucks i have a question
let them call them they have those it's
a startup shin
walks in with a friend of his who
happens to also be asian or
let's say of latin descent or or african
americans yeah
what can what happens well let's put it
this way i'll stop right there
chin doesn't walk in
because they have it it's so [ __ ] up
chris what do they have well they have a
um
they have a god i don't want i mean
i i again yesterday i walk in i'm
noticing all this [ __ ] and i'm leaving
yeah
and they actually have a separate
entrance i was like in my house i have
no idea i know but chris what happens
when
so i walk out and i'm like dude nobody
stopped you when you walked in no i know
it's your house but no nobody stopped me
no you're well you look albanian which
is technically white so there you have
it so yeah
so i walked into the part you know you
know the you know when you walk into a
bank
and they have the first entrance and
then you have to wait for them to have
the light turn green till we open up the
second entrance yeah okay so
sort of so what happens is no when when
a bank gets robbed
if a bank gets robbed there's two
entrances right and they're one after
another and
the robber leaves the one door and then
they trap them
in the little area yeah to where they
can't leave the second door right
yeah okay yeah this starbucks
has a version of that right so chris
what and you can only make it no i'm
saying it has a it has
no problem getting past the first
entrance right right but then he has to
get he goes into the he's in the
chamber right so and then what happens
so now the second entrance that would be
a red light for
chin would see a red light so he's chris
this is when does he get his car
how does he get his coffee well he
there's i mean he's free to go anywhere
else he wants no chris you have a racist
ghost i
don't know you have your name in your
house
it's in your house you guys i don't
listen i don't know where you guys are
upset you guys want to get coffee you
just
cause i'm not a racist but that's not
the point
i don't even want i don't want to have
anything to do with you i'm not going
there
i'm not going there either no you you
got starbucks right there and you
brought them this thing that's the way
you paid for this
that's from the whites only strawberry
that's a racist coffee
and you didn't even pay for this thing
right i don't have that you can go there
every day
exactly a little bit of it i'm so what
so we're all kind of in this together
right what's the name of that
what's the name of that that what's the
name of that drink so it has two names
right
so it has it's called the simply
strawberry okay and then
and then so they said so and and then
and then
under it it says made by made with real
strawberries sugar fructose whatever
sorry it's a little red we wish that it
was
like oh my god
oh man you're one your wife
chris you have to this man that is an
aggressively raised
star by this guy in your house man
insanely you know these people
hate everyone but whites chris
dude this is [ __ ] up chris this is not
gonna look good for me
i swear you keep saying that but don't
understand pick up one
yeah imagine wake up one day you walk
into a room yeah in your house you
haven't been down that corridor or
whatever
sometimes that happens and you open up
the door well no that doesn't happen
you're trying to give you the benefit of
the doubt yeah but a
all of a sudden a bunch of green and
it's a starbucks and you're like holy
[ __ ] i had nothing to do with this
okay that's where i'm coming from right
and it happens to be
i apparently i'm realizing now a white
zone
now you're realizing that chris you've
known for a full day and you still
haven't taken action have you talked to
anybody about like in some ways
so i asked the
guy who works there right and i was like
what's his name
oh so his name yeah uh his name is uh
his his name is uh henry yeah yeah okay
it's a regular name
okay right yeah uh and so
so i asked him how did what's the deal
with this right
and he goes like this i don't have
anything to do with it nobody's
responsible he's responsible
for this insanely racist coffee shop
henry's a white guy
who
i think henry might have something to do
with him yeah he's a white guy
okay but then you but you're also going
i got nothing everybody's like there's
anybody there that took responsibility
for their insanely racist you said there
were three people yeah
three other guys two others who were two
other guys yeah henry
zach that's a great dude yeah that's a
white guy i'm not even going to ask yet
well
henry cody cody
those guys are white those are white
people cody's young
okay yeah yeah so is henry too because
he probably has those parents who are
like yeah let's call him
exactly call him jack throwback names
yeah we'll call him a throwback name
brian
witch watch this well call him a
throwback name
yeah yeah my transatlantic guy it's good
it's all right
it's also really good so so and then
cody and zach
yes and zac and zach is an older man
okay right now and he doesn't he doesn't
wear the uh the green the apron or
whatever
okay so he's the man what is he yeah
sure he's the message what's he wearing
so he's got all sorts of other [ __ ]
going on he
what he might be the one no i don't i
don't you know what i'm not sure because
he's not even wearing this starbucks
outfit what is he wearing
that's what we're saying so he has like
this
white what go on
i don't know [ __ ] going white top is
it a white just a white
smock looking thing
hold on is it a robe
yeah i mean maybe he just really got a
better he's a whiz he's a grand wizard
yeah
he's got red and black he knows he has
like
it does taste magical does he have
little symbols uh like on his uh
oh you're in this is the auto club and
then there's like an emblem you never
know the red and black shirts
like those yeah those symbols like when
you get like emoji symbols you're like
so the [ __ ] clan secretly opened the
starbucks
in your goddamn optics
you have to get them the [ __ ] out of
there dude why who for a guy's been
on his phone all the time do you have
such a small phone why don't you have a
big phone like mine an
ample phone dude
that pissed me off a terrible question
okay well that's a dumb [ __ ] question
terrible question
it's a dumb question okay man you
[ __ ] get so many hits and [ __ ]
and this podcast is successful and you
ask [ __ ] like that
that was bad chris that was bad i just
thought you'd bro i want the [ __ ]
small one okay next question okay
dude i just got off the phone with my
[ __ ] agent man
they're making a documentary about my
shoulders
[ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] believe it dude i've been trying
everything i can to get them to stop
production i'm making a [ __ ]
documentary about my shoulders
and they're they're going ahead with it
dude they're literally going ahead with
it man
and i asked him when i asked him after i
realized there was nothing i could do
to stop it i said well what are they
going to call it
they're going gonna call it
ba-boom
i'm gonna call it [ __ ] boom
[ __ ] oh for god's sake i'll [ __ ] off
oh just hit him
you're doing it at what point in his
life
did was he do he's old is this his
career was this is like he was the guy
because that makes sense in 1930 right
right village guy like you can't hear
the instruments yeah
i'm just going to do it from here
but it's not it makes me so annoyed when
they laugh
you know me too
it's not a talent oh
no it's your drunk grandpa
at christmas it's not a [ __ ] skill
but this [ __ ] smile look how
impressed he is
that guy's a that guy it's his fault
what is
like i want to know what that guy sees
all the time that
that this makes him smile what does he
see just
war all of the time just people getting
hit by cars
just his whole day people
yeah and then he's like oh not war
that's literally what he's thinking when
he sees that guy
do we have any other calling questions i
think we have one more chris
okay hey this is clint
ask chris why he looks so pissed off all
the time yeah
i know i know first of all his name is
quinn
no it's very clean hey this is clint
clint
clint [ __ ] with an n first of all
all right first of all uh all right so
yeah [ __ ] with an n yeah
so all right all right clint um
i uh i've never i've legitimately never
met anybody named clint in my life and i
never will and i 100 never will
and i know that i know i'll never meet a
guy named clinton there's no [ __ ] way
if some guy actually yeah if i were ever
to meet a guy named clinton it would be
the day i get poisoned at that time
i'll tell you that so i can't even
imagine you talking to a guy named clay
yeah i know i mentioned me talking to a
guy named
can't no i know dude i'm trying to think
about it right now yeah
i don't even who am i you know what i am
when i picture
me talking to a guy named clint i'm that
[ __ ] shadow emoji yeah do you know
what i'm talking about
who uses that that's what that is that's
that's emoji is the
emoji of me talking to a guy named clint
that's what that's what they created
that emoji for that
like what would you do about the mojo
the guy with crystal is talking about a
guy named clint oh i got it it's a
shadow we got it put it on there yeah
um and then you know there's the two
shadow emoji that's me and you talking
to a guy
[Music]
so
[Music]
know